we are tied at four votes for Nicole
four votes for Paul which means Dave ons
final vote decides it after 99 days in
the Big Brother house and a gripping
finale full of intense competition and
passionate pleas there's officially a
new title holder congratulations Nicole
et's Bryce sander joined the 23 year old
ER nurse after her big crowning moment
congratulations thank you I'm still in
shock but I'm so happy obviously and a
historic BB win first woman since Rachel
Riley Oh Rachel and the first woman to
ever beat a guy at final two you know I
didn't know that statistic and I'm very
excited that I made BB history I got a
big check you get to take home do you
know what you're doing with it yet uh
gonna pay off my student loans and gonna
take my family on a really nice vacation
well save it for my future going back to
nursing you know I'm not gonna go and
spin it on anything crazy post Julie
Chen was equally thrilled by Nicole's
win there was no emotion there was no
bitterness there were no hard feelings
so the best person one
you